uh what's your biggest vice in 2021 man
pants
buying pants
what kind of pants
cargo something like i don't know rifle
ordering [ __ ]
i try not to go into some like super
bag i just like nice pants so you're
just a pants guy
when you see me
you've always got some nice pants on
every time nice
shoes i'm not sure guy pants pants it's
a special kind of guy i like my pants
lupe was a pants guy
taste mmm lupe i remember lupe put me on
all kinds of japanese [ __ ] yes they're
okay the rest of it don't really matter
you know it's the opposite kind of take
too cause most people don't care about
their pants it's me in the pants
and the pants
and the rest is just an accessory but i
need the pants
what's the most expensive pair of pants
you've purchased
i don't know maybe like 600 700
i'm gonna be doing that type of [ __ ] i'm
a regular dude like i'd like to dress
like the manager would you go to h m in
my pants rappers huh would you go to h m
in my pants were they paying me to be
there no no like if you were like hey
look i need some pants oh look there's
an h m let me go get some because
they're like 19 i usually have pants
they have pants here i'm a little bougie
so so you should see but you just said
you weren't that kind of guy
no no no i'm not above it
would i
um so you're bougie but not bougie would
i would i if i didn't have to hmm
okay see